FLORIDA, THE REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
IS DOING EVERYTHING WRONG.
WHILE NUMBERS DON’T ACTUALLY
LIKE, DO THEY?
HERE NOW WITH MORE IN WHAT IS A
STORY, IS FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS.
AND WE WILL PUT THE SLIDES BY
THE SCREEN.
I WILL BE HONEST, I WAS
PARTICULARLY WORRIED ABOUT THE
STATE OF FLORIDA.
AND THERE’S A LOT OF OLD PEOPLE
DOWN THERE.
HOW DID YOU DO THIS?
I WOULD THINK FLORIDA WOULD HAVE
BEEN ONE OF THE WORST HIT STATES
STATES?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT, SEAN.
PEOPLE ARE PREDICTING THEM TO BE
WORST IN NEW YORK, LIKE ANOTHER
ITALY.
THEY SAID THIS WEEK ONE OF THE
NEWSPAPERS IN FLORIDA SAID WOULD
HAVE 464,000 PEOPLE HOSPITALIZED
HOSPITALIZED.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER IS 2200.
BUT WHAT WE DID A VERY EARLY WAS
FOCUS ON THE POPULATIONS WHO ARE
MOST AT RISK AS YOU MENTIONED.
OUR SENIOR CITIZENS, AND WE
INSTITUTED SCREENING FOR ALL
STAFF IMMEDIATELY, WE STOPPED
VISITATION AND WE WERE REQUIRED
ALL STAFF TO WEAR LETTER AND 95
MASKS.
I CHARGE THE NATIONAL GUARD TO
DOING STRIKE TEAMS AND SPOT
TESTING AT THE FACILITY TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT IF ANY OF THE
STAFF ARE A SYMPTOMATIC.
WHENEVER THERE WAS AN INCIDENT
AT A NURSING HOME WE SEND TO
THESE RESPONSE TEAMS TO GO AND
TRY TO LIMIT SOME INFECTIONS.
WE PASS OUT ALMOST EXPLAIN MASKS
MASKS, AND WE WORKED WITH THE
VILLAGES EXCLUSIVELY.
HERE’S THE THING, YOU DON’T HAVE
TO BE DRACONIAN.
AT THE VILLAGES THEY ARE PLAYING
GOLF LIKE THEY ALWAYS DO BUT
THEY ARE DOING THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THEY DON’T SHARE A CART WITH
ANYONE AND DON’T TOUCH THE
FLAGSTICK AND THEY HAVE DONE A
VERY WELL.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
CONGRATULATIONS.
THAT’S PEOPLE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL, WORKING WITH THE STATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WELL
AND WE STILL HAVE MORE WORK TO
DO.
BUT CLEARLY, WE HAVE DONE WELL,
WAY BETTER THAN ALL THE EXPERTS
SAID WE WOULD.
>> Sean: AND I’VE BEEN THERE
TO THE VILLAGES.
THEY DO A LOT OF DRINKING, AND
THANKFULLY, IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
WENT RIGHT AT THE MOST VALUABLE
POPULATION.
WE ARE TELLING PEOPLE, DON’T
HIDE IN YOUR HOUSE.
EXACTLY.
PEOPLE PLAY GOLF AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THEY ARE
MAINTAINING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
IT’S NOT GREAT, SO I THINK THEY
DID IT THE RIGHT WAY.
I DON’T THINK THEY WORK
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
THESE NUMBERS ARE AMAZING, GREAT
WORK.